hello my name is Camila s cesas and I am
a scientist in R&D at Dow where I
deliver analytical Solutions using my
expertise in measurement science and art
programming have you ever been eager to
jump into a coding project intended to
help others but then were disappointed
by the development process this was me
when I first started coding tools for my
fellow R&D scientists who are not
programmers I suspect I'm not alone do
you remember what your biggest source of
frustration was for me it was the
maddening back and forth between feature
requests people changing their minds
about the final product and rewriting
code under a tight deadline in addition
to unexpected technical
challenges we can't control the
unexpected however by controlling our
urge to code prematurely we can improve
improve the impact efficiency and
experience of our development process my
goal is to share the lessons I've
benefited from and convince you to
invest time and energy into non-coding
tasks don't worry let's tackle this at
the beginning to avoid major course
Corrections when we're deeply engaged in
coding demos deployment and
implementation I learned to dig deeper
during the brainstorming and data
inspection phases and gain essential
technical information
by playing three roles I will
demonstrate why using the analytical R&D
lab as an example but I believe this
approach is useful across many areas and
scenarios the mission of analytical
scientists in R&D is to problem solve
diverse materials and complex
chemistries by interpreting and
combining large volumes of data from
different instruments scientists
typically adapt their data workflows to
commercial software not not the other
way around which is why they need your
expertise to dream design and execute
the vision for their custom tools
specifically they need guidance on how
to extract more value from their
measurement data with code and what
infrastructure packages and resources
suit their needs let's step away from
paet workbench temporarily visit
collaborators in their natural habitat
and explore together your first
assignment is to be a detective shadow
your users to discover their sources of
paino and inefficiencies by asking
questions as they load samples run
measurements and analyze data you will
identify Clues and assumptions that are
overlooked when these steps are simply
described to you for example you notice
that your users can export data in a
different format that is easier to parse
or that it's possible to save time and
avoid copy pasting Errors By extracting
instrument metadata from a file
otherwise ignored
next be an architect present your
discoveries to the team on the drawing
board help them create the big picture
and map the path forward brace yourself
to negotiate structural and aesthetic
preferences and balance time frame cost
and risk constraints another potential
challenge is getting users on board with
the solutions they need instead of
replicating their favorite software
features maybe your users are fixated on
how they like to edit it annotate graphs
in Excel because they haven't grasped
the benefits of reproducible and
interactive plots yet maybe you've been
tasked with building a web app but
you've identified that what they need is
an automated and scheduled report my
point is here's your chance to pitch
your approach and influence the
foundation of the project in a rewarding
way finally as a chef choose the perfect
ingredients how to season and prepare
them think of it as PL planning ahead
for a big demo dinner party and
anticipating the right amount of food to
cook to keep your project on track
imagine people asking can we test more
data sets to increase our confidence did
we account for both PDF and CSV files
however it might be too late or tricky
to incorporate these changes my
intention is not to dismiss the
iteration process or testing new ideas
as a project evolves instead agreeing on
the representative data sets and require
performance early will set the stage for
a sweet and satisfying recipe for
success I hope that inspired you to
engage with your stakeholders and
collaborators as a detective architect
and Chef try it for your next project
and reach out to discuss more I love
brainstorming in the space and it's
better when we do it together thank you
for
listening